aquí estábamos 2013 todos dependemos de
la tecnología para comunicarnos para
hacer transacciones bancarias y no
sabemos cómo leer ni escribir código el
primer programa que escribí preguntaba
cosas como cuál es tu color favorito o
cuántos años tienes escribió un programa
para jugar al gato primero aprendí cómo
hacer que un círculo verde y un cuadrado
rojo aparecieran en la pantalla solo
estás tratando de hacer algo tratando de
transferir algo desde tu mente hacia la
computadora o a una tableta es una es
una es una experiencia la limitante en
el sistema es que no hay suficiente
gente que esté entrenada y que tenga
estas habilidades hoy los programadores
de mañana serán los magos del futuro ya
sabes parecerá que tienes poderes
mágicos comparando te con cualquier otro
los mejores programadores de hoy en día
son como las estrellas de rock del
momento eso es todo